mesdames et messieurs je suis devant
vous et le thème qui m'a été donnée
je me suis jusqu'à présent demandé
pourquoi bon dieu c'est à moi qu'on l'a
décidé de confier ce thème un thème
aussi vaste qu'ambigu aussi individuel
que collectif le thème sur le sens de
l'honneur
il est d'une telle ambiguïté que ces
significations en sont multiples et ses
perceptions aussi diverses que
paradoxale alors comment sauver mon
honneur
dans toute cette affaire là
alors je pouvais comme l'a dit tout à
l'heure madame touré
refuser ou récuser mais j aurais
certainement perdu un peu de mon âme et
mon honneur de consultant au passage ou
même de conférencier tout simplement
non
j'ai décidé
que je vais présenter ce thème
parce que comme dit un proverbe bien
connu et bien c'est l'honneur qui fait
l'homme avec un grand h
et je ne pouvais pas donc manquer ce
rendez-vous comme on dit au village mais
honneur là c'est quoi même
et bien tout simplement pour faire un
peu d'étymologie
cela vient du latin au nord le vocable
honneur dit montesquieu est un préjugé
de chaque personne et de chaque
condition
il est fondé sur la tradition liée à la
fierté que l'on a de son rang et la
crainte dans déchoir dans l'entreprise
on retrouve cette logique de l'honneur à
l'intérieur de chaque service alors
retenons que
l'honneur
n'est ni défini par la raison ni par la
foi ni par la force du prince
il est fixé par la tradition et établi
des devoirs précis et des moeurs
particulières pour chaque groupe
le nord où l'honneur
c'est tout d'abord dès l'époque
carolingienne un bien donné par le
souverain en échange d'un service rendu
il s'agit d'une récompense d'abord
viagère puis plus tard et d'éditeurs
l'honneur pour vous en parler
dire son rôle nodal donc des traditions
et des valeurs qui s'y rattachent le
sens de l'honneur se base sur des
valeurs convenu sur des principes
acceptés de la majorité est un des think
tanks avery 15 watts qui se posent la
question en tant que citoyen de
l'afrique de l'ouest en particulier dans
sa revue mata ki numéro 5 de d'octobre
2010 est sur les valeurs africaines dont
nous nous réclamons aujourd'hui
alors les valeurs qu'est ce que c'est
on considère comme valeur
tout fait social ou de culture qui est
conforme à la raison à la nature de
l'homme
et qui répondent positivement aux
besoins fondamentaux ça m'est offert aux
besoins fondamentaux de la majorité des
membres d'une communauté humaine
de ce point de vue les valeurs revêtent
un caractère dynamique et permettent
ainsi à l'individu de vivre en équilibre
harmonieux aussi bien avec lui même
qu'avec les autres
les valeurs sont des phénomènes qu'il
faut savoir saisir on peut parler de
valeur qu'en terme essentiellement
relatif car les valeurs se rapporte
toujours le plus souvent aux conditions
de vie et aux intérêts de la société
qu'il ait produit alors tout à l'heure
on avait fait appel à google moi j'ai
fait appel à wikipedia
wikipedia nous rappelle que l'on arrête
un sentiments d'estimé et de
considération portée à un individu ayant
une conduite digne méritante conforme à
un certain nombre de normes d'un groupe
ou d'une société c'est un lien entre une
personne et un groupe social qui lui
donne son identité et lui confère le sb
en remarquant et ans
descendant dans les profondeurs de mes
recherches j'ai constaté tout simplement
que l'honneur n'est jamais gratuit il se
conquiert par les reflets mais aussi par
les petits gestes que nous pouvons poser
quotidiennement
ce sont des gestes qui font la
différence
provoquant au passage
admiration sociale ou considération
collective à la différence de la vertu
qui est un attribut individuel l'honneur
est quasiment un attribut sociale qui
confère à celui qui en bénéficie
l'orage mérite reconnu par les siens ou
par les autres
l'honneur ne se donne pas soi même
l'honneur que l'on n'a vient des autres
c'est eux qui reconnaissent notre valeur
notre excellence notre avant et qui
confère cet attribut là en reconnaissant
que nous sommes dignes de ce qu'ils
disent par exemple quand des directions
des institutions des ong ou autres
services
valorise et reconnaissent par un acte
public la qualité de votre travail
son originalité son excellence et tirait
et vous affiche sur un tableau d'honneur
et bien il y a que conséquemment les
travailleurs vont vous admirez vont vous
féliciter que vous devenez une identité
remarquable
grâce à la qualité du travail
et je peux assurer que depuis la nuit
des temps des femmes et les hommes lutte
pour décrocher de telles distinctions au
travail en amour ont le pouvoir pour
l'argent pour les affaires et pour
beaucoup d'autres choses encore une
compétition à la vie ou à la mort est
engagé
chacun veut quelque part sauver son
honneur et je peux vous dire et chacun
le sait que cette
tyrannie boulimique conduit certains
l'ameublement à l'égoïsme orbite voir un
l'égotisme névrosé
écrasant les autres dans un redoutable
fracas du poids de leurs envahissante
personnalité de nos jours ils sont
partout au bureau comme sur les réseaux
sociaux on tue on se tue pour l'honneur
en france pour l'honneur
cette quête forcenée déshonneur rebute
souvent certains méritants qui préfèrent
alors
fuir ces honneurs pour vivre une vie
faite de simplicité et de dignité dans
leur petit coin
selon une chercheuse appeler madame
yolande diallo dans son livre l'afrique
traditionnelle
savez vous que la plupart des conflits
sont nés à l'occasion des différends
relatifs soit aux questions de bien donc
de richesses au pouvoir ou à
des fraises se sont tués par pour ces
questions et perd ou tuer leurs enfants
pour ces questions vous connaissez bien
pardon vous connaissez bien l'histoire
africaine et elles foisonnent de ces
exemples-là rappelons que les guerres
les questions de vengeance ou de
revanche trouve souvent leurs racines
dans les épiphénomènes relatif au sens
de l'honneur
conséquemment
l'honneur ne vient pas de nous il est
donné par les autres c'est le groupe où
la société qui donne cette action
humaine à nos actions l'honneur ne
s'arrache guerre il se mérite il vient à
celui qui le mérite pour saluer sa
grandeur
quel que soit son statut social
le sens de l'honneur et l'exigence est
exigences de conquête raisonner et de
défense responsable je m'explique
quand vous avez était élevé vous avez
bénéficié d'un honneur vous devriez
pouvoir le mériter et comment le mériter
sinon quand le défendant en devenant par
votre exemplarité une identité
appréciable c'est à dire qu'il faut
savoir rester au niveau de la confiance
conquise et avoir la lucidité de
préserver cette élévation sociale faire
toujours mieux mais jamais - outreau ça
donne est
resté digne malgré les tempêtes de la
vie par respect de votre élévation par
les autres il arrive hélas les frères et
soeurs
qu'on tue au nom de l'honneur
la logique de l'honneur et quelquefois
insaisissable
vous avez certainement entendu parler
des crimes d'honneur mesdames et
messieurs d'ailleurs ils ne sont pas
limitées à une seule culture ni à une
seule religion selon nos enquêtes selon
les nations unies il touche un grand
nombre de pays de cultures très diverses
je citerai entre l'afghanistan l'albanie
l'arabie saoudite le bangladesh la
bosnie herzégovine l'inde l'indonésie
l'iran l'irak israël la jordanie
l'ouzbékistan le pakistan la palestine
la somalie le soudan là syrie la turquie
le yémen et j'en passe cela figure dans
la fondation ségur 2012
certains observateurs font remarquer que
la majorité des crimes d'honneur sont
commis dans des pays d'asie du sud est
du moyen orient et dans d'autres régions
d'afrique et même d'amérique latine et
d'europe
l'onu estime que les crimes d'honneur
en sont les crimes d'honneur c'est 1000
femmes sont victimes de crimes d'honneur
chaque année en fait il est généralement
admis que ce chiffre est largement
sous-estimée
et les hommes poussent la bêtise un peu
plus loin en s'engageant dans le
contrôle de la sexualité des femmes et
le maintien de la domination masculine
avec les mutilations génitales féminines
dont vous connaissez les conséquences
dramatiques mais objectivement
aucune raisons liées à la culture à la
coutume à la religion à la tradition ou
aux prétendus sens de l'honneur ne
saurait justifier les mutilations
génitales
mesdames et messieurs souvenons nous
j'aime mieux mourir que choir dans la
honte c'était écrit et roland à
roncevaux dans la chanson de roland
composé vers la fin du xième siècle onze
siècles après
souvenons nous le 29 septembre
1898 aux soldats de la colonne du
capitaine gouro venus l'arrêter
l'almamy samory touré empereur du
wassoulou avait vaillamment prononcé
cette célèbre historique est immortel
sentence
sayaka fille sa maladie
plutôt la mort que la honte
savez vous par exemple mais choisit ce
que de nombreuses guerres n'avait pour
but en réalité que de se procurer des
esclaves pour des travaux des champs ici
moyens dans des sociétés essentiellement
qui rien même si
comme parade on évoquait des questions
d'honneur soulier
arguments fallacieux
mais en tant qu homme de lettres je suis
toujours séduit par l'inoubliable
discours de monsieur pierre messmer
chancelier de l'institut à marseille le
mardi 3 septembre 2002 quand il disait
sur le sens de l'honneur
valeurs sociales et sentiments
personnels
4 expliquer comment des arguties du
point d'honneur cornélien aux honneurs
que l'on reçoit souvent avec une feinte
de modestie du code de l'honneur qui
dicte la vendetta en l'honneur du
travail bien fait ou au respect de la
parole donnée la parole d'honneur les
significations se chevauchent se
croisent et rend le sujet difficile à
saisir et plus encore à être exposés
comme je tente de le faire ce soir
madame et monsieur
mourir pour la patrie
[Musique]
sacrifier sa vie au service des autres
pratiquer la transparence dans la
gestion des affaires de l'état
garantir les pratiques démocratiques en
politique sont autant d'opportunités
civique pour celui qui a le sens de
l'honneur
celui qui de toute sa vie ne veut voir
son nom mêlé à la magouille à la gabegie
ou à la triche et bien c'est point
d'honneur deviendront pour lui des
points cardinaux que la boussole du sens
de l'honneur pourra facilement lui
indiquer et cela pour toujours je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]